dans toute cette saga Hockey Canada a
réussi un exploit rare faire l'unanimité
au Parlement l'opinion est partagée par
tous les partis Andreas Kenner doit être
le premier demi-nois tombé distille
sont en place moi je vois pas le numéro
du tunnel devant le comité du patrimoine
en début de semaine madame Skinner avait
défendu becquet ongles son organisation
le lendemain Hockey Québec désavouait la
fédération nationale ça a été l'élément
déclencheur selon ce député du Bloc
québécois
exécutif de la haute direction et c'est
ça qui est problématique quand elle se
félicite du travail de Scott Smith qui a
dit que la faute est aux autres est
forcément elle n'a pas joué son rôle et
c'est pour ça mon avis qui est l'occupée
les élus réclament davantage de
changement déjà 5 des 9 membres du CA ne
seront pas de retour après l’assemblée
générale du mois de décembre deux
d'entre eux écoutent leur dernier mandat
un autre de se représentera pas tandis
que Michael brin d'amour et Andreas
Kenner ont démissionné à l'unisson les
parlementaires demande aussi la taille
du directeur général du scotchmex c'est
le grand ménage qui doit être opéré par
Hockey Canada actuellement on est encore
dans une opération de camouflage madame
scanner passe pour une bouc émissaire
dans les circonstances ce n'est pas à
elle de payer pour l'ensemble des des
choses qu'on reproche actuellement en
quai Canada au cœur du problème la
structure de gouvernance un ancien juge
de la Cour suprême doit remettre un
rapport à sujet dans les prochaines
semaines il ne s'agit pas seulement de
faire table rase du CA mais d'identifier
le profil des gens qui devraient s'yé je
pense que si il y a des nouvelles
personnes nous structuration la
confiance va venir peu à peu les
commanditaires vont revenir et je pense
qu'on va pouvoir aller de l'avant de son
côté à Québec n'a pas souhaité commenter
ce dernier rebondissement le président
du conseil d'administration Claude
Fortin s'est contenté de dire qu'il
allait laisser à qui Canada gérer sa
crise ici Alexandre gascon Radio-Canada
à Montréal